gamespot people gamespot viewers thanks
for joining us on another episode of
whatever we're calling this show now and
i'm kevin van noord senior editor and
we're going to be playing shadowrun
chronicles today and over skype it's
very exciting we've got we've got jaan
Wagner and Mitch gittleman from two
different developers so guys I think I
think I think you're in the best
situation to explain why there are
people from two different developers on
the stream today so welcome yeah thanks
for having us absolutely the simple
reason is that too shadowrun games out
there one is the excellent Harebrained
Schemes share on returns chatter on
dragon fall into shadow on Hong Kong and
the other is our more modest shadowrun
Chronicles and the reason is we all have
SAT around so much we just wanted two
games right Mitch isn't that reason
that's exactly the reason and we have
you know and this game shadowrun
Chronicles is a multiplayer game and
shadowrun returns Dragon Ball calm our
single player rpgs right yeah so that's
also the reason why we can play together
which is in the nice thing and then
Mitch was nice enough to make the time
out of his busy schedule to help us play
the game which is awesome and I'm sad
because I was playing on the closed beta
branch until about 15 minutes ago so I
started all from scratch my poor
character I named her Florence because
that seemed right so what do you what do
you do so are we good shall we Jack we
heard so so this is just a build-up
screen so we see the team composition
great and we just push start and then
off we go so this is the mission that
Mitchell denotes because we fail at it
last time around when he was yes I did
and I wanted to give him a chance to
redeem himself in front of them and
they're in the eye of the public yeah
and I think it's important to note that
it wasn't it wasn't single player I
didn't just fail I fail for my entire
team so you didn't feel bad just for you
but for all of us and how you let us
down or them down
yeah so this is one the matter life and
multiplayer so there's more there's not
to be no pressure at all okay so this is
a stadium that a dragon crashed into
right now and as a shadow runner you
obviously not there to save people you
are there because it's a great
opportunity to steal stuff your task
with stealing the trophy of the Red Sox
several surface of the Red Sox and the
dragon just crashed into Fenway which is
why we see a lot of fires burning I'm
actually as a group leader I have a
second character that I better play
usually if you're four people then you
can obviously play for life players or
any missing players are gonna be filled
up by npc search right since we all know
the game we can just sort of call out
stuff and I think I need to see what my
other characters you can do I first note
is watch out for the crazed guard guns
they're crazy and they're like thanks
yeah just a note k star guard dog is
crazed yeah yeah little beer of choice
whoo okay there's a dragon you can hear
man that can't be good yeah I don't
think it means anything it's just
general noise you find in the stadium
often okay I see what they are up to the
guard dog said wolf actually we've got
these little what we call mudo moot by
city moved comments so when you do
something there's there's a possibly a
whole chain of comments from the old
down we already we've attracted more
people that we can probably finish up
that's all right we can do that we can
do this I know ok we can almost do that
well anyway I'm gonna help you here with
the I was hoping you would I'm just
going to try and stun this guy one thing
you may notice that we can all move at
the same time even though it's turn
based right so you can all make decision
at the same time but when somebody
actually starts then you'll this will be
executed before anybody else connect so
you still know whatever somebody else
did yeah there's ghosts there was a
spirit I figured he wouldn't last long
but you know good for distraction
purposes absolutely it's a good meat
shield ok a little bit of concentration
because otherwise we're going to lose
that mission more less amusing
they're your family and I'm going to
much better balance so yes there we go I
think I see a lootcrate back here oh
yeah all over the place so just one kris
carr top left i think we should make
short work of that oh no get already you
oh lets you go to lie arlene it leaders
down okay which I don't think is yeah I
don't I don't even think it's you it's
it's actually difficult mission if you
don't go in with with a good slug I did
last time well yeah yeah okay so what'll
happen is we we from now on we've got
five turns to finish the mission which
is practically impossible just when I'm
other group members dies it yeah you're
gonna have five strands to do anything
I'm like eight development let's just
try that again emma louise i think that
sounds lovely I just feel good that I'm
now I wasn't the weak point that's
that's sadly important to me okay we'll
just go in good have you on the team and
to this again it's it's just good to be
here and hold my own I think it's cool
that the biggest losers are the two
professional game developers yeah that's
something that I mean obviously it's
because we we don't have time to play
too many games but also we're a bit
cocky to be honest I mean it's just we
we do stuff because we think we know
what we're doing and then it turns out
with maybe not I still got bloody mary
isn't that the definition of an
entrepreneur ah i see that letting Mary
in the missions icons yet invite her so
guys while we wait i guess i have a
question so if you've played the pre the
single-player shadowrun games you know
how much will those skills that you've
learned
translate into shadowrun Chronicles I
think one thing you should know right
away is don't get to a far ahead of your
teammates like I did yesterday that
translates really well young what do you
think I think I mean the i would say in
the in Iran returns games you cost a lot
more story in depth and there's there's
that the comet is more forgiving I would
say so you can you know we can I think
you just proved that it is twice in a
row and four hours it's actually I mean
this is this is particularly dangerous
mission because they're coming at you
right right you know from the start but
we are definitely more calmed oriented
our story we don't have that creative
story and we do have a story in the
background everything else but the focus
is especially because it's a it's a
co-op game the focus is on on the combat
and it'll help you if you if you know
turn-based it'll definitely help you but
a lot of the skills are slightly
different with us more it's morbid
somewhere between XCOM and ensure to
play a lot of XCOM I say right um like
Kevin I can't get you I was not back I
think it's because I spoke this medley
oh maybe and it knocked me back so you
may need to bring me back okay I'm I'm
seeing you as in mission no that's
actually okay I got you I got you back
but I don't have Bloody Mary Mitch are
you in a mission so I'm right where we
were okay yeah I don't see either of you
I decided to wait for my leader and
learn my lesson are hardly did you start
the mission already no no no I'm right
and back where we were when we went down
yeah okay let's read our constant
I try that again losing grip closed yes
I have been transferred to my own
location which is where I just was kind
of sore knees but you can you can spend
your time putting in some experience
probably yeah well I wanted to all I
really want to do is have something up
on the screen people could see like if I
spoke to miss medley what that was like
ok so I'm sorry then I'm not going to
steal you from your from your mission
I'm just gonna close to again and do
this now you can roam freely and which I
think you need to restart there's
nothing just to obviously we start the
entire app yep all right well i'll go
ahead and wander around and show people
the the hub here yes and maybe we can go
speak to smedley while i wait for that
to happen and people can get an idea for
for who this guy is have you seen one
hour you've seen them all so guys
question about the voice acting and
things like that because you've
definitely got some Boston accents going
on here how much how much effort did you
guys put into making sure that you have
the the right kind of accent well first
I mean obviously we're not we're not US
base so far as it's particularly
difficult to actually be able to tell
whether to Boston accent right the wish
we got an audio director in whose from
Boston and who drilled the voice actors
on using that accent so we got a couple
of three we recorded in Chicago but a
couple of people up from Boston doing
that and the ones that went from Boston
at least on some of the the audios had
to sound like busting so that the
director actually drilled them a lot
right but it was fun because they had
they had fun trying usually usually
apparently us actors are rarely allowed
to actually have an accent
so they came in with solving you
collection and then he was like no dude
pack the calves that was really fun and
I think I mean from what Bostonians tell
me we got it off pretty well I don't
know tell you tell me that's great and
the void second saw something basically
we were looking forward to because it
creates a lot of the immersion the games
coming from data all right I'm done with
my conversation with smedley I didn't
want you to it I'm inviting you I'm in
watching Mitch again for the second try
thank you and it is amazing because you
look I'm sorry there was there other
guys voice acting if there's no voice
acting in the shadowrun shadowrun
returns dragonfall or hongkong it's all
text base like the build like baldur's
gate games and things like that and
mostly because of it just the sheer
amount of writing in the games and the
parsing within the writing you know
would be vast and we wouldn't be able to
do it but one thing but for the other
thing it's kind of funny it I really
like hearing characters voices in my
head so that I can you know make up what
they sound like but it is really fun
here to get to hear the shadowrun slang
and stuff like they're coming out of
people's mouths right yeah we're
actually people the group there's two
camps and I think that they're it having
the voice in your head has its own charm
because the characters always gone
differently it's the same money read the
book and then we watch a film and you
were like no right like that I look like
that but after time it also i find it
also goes differently we we had a german
when we do to marketing from the voices
we like one of the actors cupsy just on
the day that we were doing we're doing
the recording we could have any more
time to train with that so we got
somebody else and and and for a while I
was like nah he doesn't sound like you
know like we wanted him to but now that
I've listened a couple of times it's
like okay this is the character so it's
there was a connection change okay we're
back again the mission let's not run
away and do what let's just ignore that
and just try one Saturday but it may be
the same thing all over again like just
as well so disappointing i'm not i was
putting on not spreading out no that's
not what i wanted to do god damn it oh
no guys what are you know I me now I'm
stuck over there in the worst possible
place oh well okay okay so let's see
what I can whether we can fix it this at
least survived the first place like this
is just the first wave you know this is
the intro encounter let's go to survive
that won't we okay so good good yeah are
ok you probably want to go back from
from there because there's couple of
guys coming at you yeah that's not good
advice that's my that's my [ __ ] it's
obvious advice on our story
okay if you get away from these docs and
everything else i'll i'll just say nice
nice indeed okay what do they walk or
something are no time yeah exactly too
fast couldn't even say wolf anymore I'm
gonna I'm gonna go and use a little bit
of my bag of tricks here stay away with
a beer don't get close to me I can try
and see hang on a second yeah there we
go ah oh that's fantastic geez that's
rocket launcher well hold an was useful
I I feel like my bear was a was a proper
sacrifice for this particular instance
yeah I'm sorry I was not quite all right
I I you can do can always summon another
beer yeah there's various dime a dozen
yeah you can always have another thing
okay we threw this one that's fine
that's actually good I don't ever I kind
of a bear dance let's see this mine is
bigger than yours because it obvious
actually doesn't like having to
summoners that's nice yeah it's a mama
bear and baby basically it looks like a
bear from there's not a whole bear
family just north of them they'll
they'll change color and that gave me
larger in size so the spirit power is
reflected by the size of your bear
abortion Utley their spirits bleed a
little so they may not make it into the
next encounter there's a bit of food
over here oh my goodness what is going
on down here
to the right you are oh there's the loot
nice yeah there's some and everybody
gets loot but everybody gets different
dude so uneven we didn't want to have
the hey grab this one grab this one or
no I'm there fasten you so we didn't
want to have any loot yeah yeah that's
amazing so just whenever somebody opens
up something you get everybody gets
stuff all right okay so there's going to
be more people coming at us um I'm
getting the copper right now yeah well
this time we actually need to come to
them first so the Bears are going to
draw them out now we're doing this
tactically now and that's not the bear
that's the other guy the other guys
could draw the box yes perfect and then
we see whether we can do anything I'm
gonna sleep okay yeah us too little bear
in front of everybody else all right
good idea I feel like my bear is best
i'm probably going to move him around
when prime time moves because i'm right
there and yeah yeah so after me ok it
comes a little buddy ok no I don't know
if I want to you just n deterrent but
yeah I think I'm just gonna end it yeah
might be a good idea if anybody those
are dog cart Tom an immortals yeah
where's that rocket launcher I only have
one Oh rats that's a good time yeah well
I just be sent back no no pasa pick
their doctor
I'll just take some of the heat off
there I think your barrack comes out
this is going you I like the way he gets
in the cover to its it I've sprinted in
a position he's very adorable because he
looks like he's just trying to scratch
his back against the back the bats like
whatever he's against very cute yeah we
were having fun with a bear so what even
I do what you think you have up your
sleeve here I did I'm really not having
a lot of tricks up my sleeve but oh
there's people again out out so one of
the things that you may notice is as in
shadowrun independent paper games our
Comment actually is pretty deadly yeah
we haven't done a lot of like usually if
you have a rigger or a hacker even a
mate sometimes you can you know stand
other people are basically use is a
marked ability which sort of prepares
them for marquette I got the dog here we
test them for for being easy to it so my
work is actually one of the key
components you wouldn't know it from
looking at what we are doing but but
once you actually get the recipe for
success oh yeah ask true but he wants to
get the hang of it you actually it's not
really useful I mean we're doing an
excellent job we're doing very well ok
so now there's this there is a gate to
well whatever you to whether this where
the adjustments are right we want to
close that because otherwise we're going
to get
a couple of guys coming at us from
stairs comp but it's going to take my
bike through the gate got it so now we
want to go into the trophy room which is
the one where the sign says trophy room
surprisingly enough and there's a couple
of guys in there so you again marching
in usually marching in it's rarely ever
advised in our game as in most chair
like in the pen and paper shadow on
combat it's supposed to be really deadly
even though it's 3 second round usually
takes you half an hour to play because
of the box of dice right but we try to
emulate that and actually making it
pretty deadly and relatively quick so
when you play the game the turn itself
doesn't take that long in so for a
turn-based game where we're pretty fast
I think ok let's see anybody else I
think somebody needs to end veteran I
think I'm narrating for you guys soon
that was mean ok how do is be careful
for once ok I'll take the grace dwarf
because I can reach him and punch him
and I probably needs the bear to back me
up there ok I should just be the right
amount of damage and repair can actually
regenerate damaged from his attack so i
avenge the points on this attack good so
that will help them be more useful
oh no that's not what I wanted to do it
all that's all right I'll recover nicely
just pretend this supposed to pin all
the way okay I'm shooting some walls but
yeah ah major power yeah trying to oh
well oh well what can I say oh oh got it
it's really useful to have that bear
yogi no that's what the bear is for
really it is that's i'm doing an area
effect nice fun okay i'm not really one
guy left good position here anybody want
to take that loss Oh crazy out he's only
got six hit points left you know you can
do help get him oh that was this Prince
fight yeah that's a good that's close
but no but I'll try another check there
nope look yeah I feel like I'm not
really am right we need you hang on just
one up Oh boom but what you've done to
me and I'm not even I'm not even wearing
any armor that's that's that's better
that's unfortunate it is but ok let's
put her out of her misery yeah yeah that
was a little overkill there I withdrawal
right to it I don't do halfway yeah 12
hi everyone ok that's actually one of
the audio look well though the locks we
have to have so they tell little stories
random or they also give background on
what's happening in the levels sometimes
it just give you background on the game
so one will actually mention our backers
or Kickstarter people from the forums as
well funny so we need to end their turn
that's always me okay if I'm going to
open that door does anybody have a black
man a ball or something got it okay
because there's going to be a couple of
people on the other side of that door
and I yay well done good start so I'm
going to get a meat shield yeah Oh Beth
bearable sort of ooh nice ya see if I
can get can you get to the first I can't
but not with the bear oh you can how can
I I was just full movie isn't there yeah
that was a most which is all right I I
just really want him in there to take
off them yeah as long as things are
usually rai this is when it's got comes
it using you usually moving away i'm
getting in a better position right i can
actually try and chase it with your
malay guys I'm gonna just yeah well done
I think this time we actually sent a
transmitting it really getting sprint
possibilities just because of bloody
marys position so maybe I'm not really
in a good spot that worked out anyway
yeah there's one left over there there's
one up there yeah she's just up that
means she's come to a lot of damage if
she hits you automatically crits like
ice the barrels the bear is gonna be
alright he's just uh yeah he's just ago
serious people you'll just get reappear
in the spirit plane I can't be true and
this would go well only twenty-five
percent chance but yeah sometimes you're
lucky yeah nice job the one thing that's
walking to really will smash all right
okay so grab the two trophies over there
that remain and then we head back and we
still alive not go Birdo
climb
okay okay okay time to get out of here
that's it I have the feeling it's not
going to go quite quite smoothly that's
just a thought I don't know where you
could possibly what I could possibly
think that it's just a movement should
be fine I think I'll wait for you guys
to catch up purchase online really was
yeah there's these guys Roman the door
that we closed a couple of guys that has
been consistently smashing it trying to
get out the door is now at 36 health and
they're doing like 24 things turn which
means until we all there it's probably
just about to barge through it time for
the bear I I do very much like playing a
summoner so yeah i'm guessing the
shield's but oh you have a few stuff now
you tell us oh I'm just trying to get
one of them while they're still in there
i don't i'm not sure where i can text
them i think we've nary a spell for that
only I can attack gay magic there's
something there's really something about
having a smart gun casting some sort of
mana bolts spell and standing near
boston red sox logo it just says shallow
ones so loudly
okay we can take them out maybe not all
they actually come through the door
which is that list oh there's this dude
over here I didn't even see this dude
over here all right on that case
somebody has a malleable now it's a good
time yeah as soon as i get my turn okay
i'll make them if they're pay with their
lives oh yeah there's space the other
section so we we're sorry I'm moving my
bear because I don't want my I don't
want floor enough to get hit so I'm
hoping they'll pay attention to the
Bears just ahead but we hope romana oh
man there I go and my bear oh all in the
one that's all right I'm chicken fruit
we're gonna I'm praying for you guys
hope that'll help you can do this you
can do this okay let's see um mich we
don't yet Peele everybody we can just
make a run for it oh I'm a completist
but ok whatever you say that I'm not
saying we have to I'm just saying we can
that might be the way to go that's how I
completed a mission right before the
wipe so yeah it's it's perfectly
legitimate let's see I can okay there's
a this guy's gonna die oh crap oh
alright alright I get your point yeah
yeah yeah chris tarrant berserk so
they're doing a lot of damage so it just
occurred to me you know i just you know
you're a German who gave the dough I
don't want to pretend like I'm from
finance the yawn you're in good shape
your full health you should be able to
yeah I also run for tins and yeah get
this mission done and you get a rear
guard going to look over and pig call
this one is going to die across the
berserks gonna do a little downstream so
yeah let's make the bear target
we he just says we nobody will warn the
spirit there sadly the Crazy Horse
really love what they do okay so real
they're totally into their jobs yeah
they're dead expected oh there's
somebody shooting oh bloody marys down
what happens when you just run for it
see the good thing uh because no and the
last guy yeah I actually escaped by well
I know what the frag just went down
there to guess just bought it what it
was talking so that's good news he's
she's uh she may be laying back there on
the battlefield but she'll always truly
be with us see I love seeing this
mission success your definition of
success in mine might be a little
different it's a there was a team
success you know if just one of us makes
it out of life it's good because you
know the mission has been accomplished
and everything else has been covered by
doc wagon anyway all right very well
okay well we've done it wow that's the
true um now was there was there more
that you wanted to do today or was this
more he wanted to give people an example
of what a mission with this is this is
basically what we like to show and I
think one of the things that we did show
is that it's difficult yeah which it
should be and that you need teamwork
which we just no proven is required also
that you don't have to kill everybody in
order to succeed so it's not a you know
clean the level and you get to XP but
you know whatever brings you to the
mission there's missions that you can
play without ever actually engaging in
comment at all so so sometimes
discretion is the better part of later
so yeah right that's pretty much what
wallet show and I think it's worth
mentioning to that when I was playing
earlier and I could take henchmen out
into the field and it didn't necessarily
and as we had there as well you know it
doesn't necessarily have to be have to
be live players if you want to
just can also bring bring a I along for
the ride as well exactly yeah you can
play basically what the point is you
play co-op and there's there's actually
this is other players characters so the
way it works out is other players I'm
just going to leave you so you get the
nicer nice of you from your bub Here I
am there's there's other players
characters that you can take so or
almost all of the characters that you
have as henchman are created by other
players and then they're automatically
scaled to your level of competence
rightly so you always get sort of the
right members of the team but the
difference between life players and
henchmen is that entrance only have one
skill tree one active skill tree so
they're more of an archetype so they're
more really like the mage de Charmin the
street Sam where players have at least
two skill free state they usually can
bring along and so a little more
versatile which gives you a little more
tactics but they're not stronger or
weaker so it's not about points or
anything it's just being able to put
more different tactics into the field
alright but then as we can see that
there the downside is that that
coordination is is little harder to do
if you are the team that obviously
everybody that's what you want them to
do which makes it easier for people of
course here in the hub there there's a
there a variety of vendors so no matter
what what class you chose or what
weapons you like you you have all all
that you need right here in this hub
yeah yeah I'll pass the vendors that
also some of the vendors and love the
NTC seem to have what we call optional
commentary so we don't string you along
a specific you know you don't get the
quest go to a and then go to be and you
know take this from B to C so right get
through all of them because its co-op
you don't want to necessarily join
somebody who's clicking away 500
dialogues so what we do is you can you
can have that background if you play
single player if you play as a group you
can have that specific background
information and there there's little
story is unfolding from that that will
actually also be relevant so and while
there's always one
emphasis vanishes because he's suspected
to be a thief and one of the things that
we're going to do is one of our players
is going to decide how that story
continues what what is going to happen
to bozeman is being determined by one of
our players that will be created in an
upcoming event so so 10 tears can the
guy wins that event can actually make
the decision right so we spring the
story line along key plot points based
on what the players to write well Jana
Mitch thanks for joining me before we
before we say goodbye good afternoon
good evening depending on where it is
that you are in the world is there
anything else that you wanted to make
sure people knew before we before we cut
away which you should pitch your games
we talking intelligible arguing not
entirely too much you just you just
released and congratulations but you can
go to steam right now and get shadowrun
returns or shadowrun dragon Falls
director's cut and we'll be putting out
shadowrun Hong Kong later this summer
we're also making a game called golem
arcana you can go to golem arcana com
hear about that Devlin's miniatures
board gaming like warhammer 40k with
smart devices like your iPhone and iPad
connects those together so they teach
you how to play and keep track it's
really a lot of fun and then also you
can go to the game calm and see I knew
our new work-in-progress it's a cross
between Dark Souls and those roguelike
games and it's a really good looking
game you should check that out it's
really cool I can I can just highly as
somebody who's making art and
multiplayer games this is nice right up
my alley search it's great oh good great
and of course let's not forget shadowrun
Chronicles and the rest of the title
which I've suddenly dropped out of my
head Thank You Boston lockdown how could
I forget but gentlemen thanks for
joining me thanks everybody out there
for for joining me and you should see a
review for
for shadowrun chronicles Boston lock
down soon which is good news and in the
meanwhile I guess we'll see you the next
time on whatever live stream it is that
we do next I'm Kevin Van Orden thanks
for joining